one is in Tampa hi Juan welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
today better than I deserve what's up so
my wife and I have been married for
eight years we have five beautiful
children within five years we've made a
lot of bad financial decisions and we
find ourselves to the tune of about 97
grand in debt so just about 100 grand
and dad not including the house and I
want to just follow the plan as its
stated on the app about the police
resistance
guy right here which is parsley why I
find myself in this predicament but I
just want to follow the plan the way
it's written she seems to think that by
maybe utilizing or taking money out of
our 401k to pay down a big chunk of this
debt it would help us get a good head
start and then essentially we'd be
paying ourselves back and I don't mean
borrowing money out of the 401k yes
correct all right no I would not do that
and the reasons are twofold number one
when you leave your company and you will
leave your company when you die when you
get a better job and quit or when they
fire you one of those three things will
cause you to leave you can leave your
company when you leave your company if
that loan has not been repaid it is
considered an early withdrawal and
you'll be taxed to at your rate plus a
10% penalty on that amount and I would
never do that for that reason number two
you know mutual funds are performing way
better than you would be paying yourself
here's the problem the intrinsic problem
in that question are in that suggestion
is not even the tax you know I just gave
you the real reasons not to do a 401k
loan that's not really the problem the
problem is you guys got into debt
looking for a shortcut to get stuff that
you couldn't afford now you're looking
for a shortcut to get out and there's
not one
understood that's the problem you really
have to the two of you together sit down
and go you know what we are not going to
live our life as a life of shortcuts
we're going to live like no one else so
that later we can live and give like no
one else and that that's what's at the
center of this and I don't blame her I
would rather do something of the easiest
way to but it ends up here's the other
thing that you can bring up and you guys
can talk through one of the things I
found I found this many years ago the
first time I've seen it in several
studies since then but first time I saw
it it was just I open to me that wealthy
people when they are making decisions
about purchases or money decisions have
a planning window an analysis a calendar
window of ten or twenty years out they
ask themselves when I do this is it
smart ten or twenty years out poor
people that stay poor broke people that
stay poor have a planning window of
Friday thank God is Friday
oh god it's Monday does this feel good
right now in other words and the
question of the you know borrowing on
your 401k is not quite Friday but it's
by Christmas it feels better but if you
look out ten years
it didn't look better at all it's a
really dumb idea to have put your whole
whole thing at risk on a thirty percent
or 40 percent hit at that rate now you
know I can't make anybody do anything
and I don't try to so your wife is going
to think what she's going to think you
guys are going to do what you're going
to do but those are the reasons that I
don't recommend using borrowed money on
your 401k number one your unplugging
good investments that might have made
you twelve and you're going to pay
yourself five or six it might have made
you more than twelve number two when you
leave your company if you have not paid
the loan back you have a huge mess
because you're gonna get hit with your
tax rate plus ten percent so that's
probably a 30 or a 40 percent hit
on that money it's like borrowing money
at 30% interest is why you don't cash
out your 401k to pay off your debts
number 3 it's a sense of a shortcut
that's not real and just like going into
debt in the first place it was a
shortcut to get stuff that wasn't real
and it causes your problems number four
it's short-term thinking instead of
long-term thinking and wealthy people
always use long term thinking by the way
almost all long-term thinking has
short-term pain almost all short-term
thinking has long-term pain and
short-term relief and that's what this
is it's short-term relief with long-term
pain and that's how you know what's
wrong that's how you know it's the wrong
way to go and there's just no shortcut
to any places worth going so those are
your four reasons that's why you don't
do it now you guys get to sit down talk
about whether you're gonna do it or not